Speaker 1: Welcome back to The David Pakman
Show. My name is Jesse Dolma, I'm sitting
in for David Pakman while I was on vacation.
Thanks, David. I appreciate the opportunity
to talk to your audience. Hey, you know how
Donald Trump ruined the Red Hat for everybody
except for Magga, Turd's? Well, I mean, it's
a funny story here. Kevin McCarthy has now
ruined the red shirt and really taken the
Magga concept, the Magga hat concept to a
whole new level. Because if you've ever been
at breakfast, if you live in an area with
a lot of Maggard, people will keep it respectable
or will try and you see across the parking
lot someone approaching and they have a red
hat and you keep watching to see if it's going
to be a Nike swoosh or if it's going to be
a Magga hat. And if you've if you've thought
about well, I don't think I want to own a
red hat just in case someone thinks I'm that
guy, I'm with you. I've been that, too. But
Kevin McCarthy, in response to Nancy Pelosi
calling him a moron or reportedly calling
him a moron, is now selling T-shirts on his
website with more on on them. And then in
small, much smaller letters, the definition.
So if you're that guy across the parking lot,
approaching the the the store front, all you
see is someone wearing a t shirt proclaiming
themselves to be a moron. I'm going to read
from his website here. Oppose the moronic
Marzook mandate with this exclusive T-shirt.
Nancy Pelosi just called Kevin McCarthy a
moron for opposing the mosque mandate. By
the way, verbally and parenthetically, here
you are, a moron, Kevin McCarthy, if you're
opposing a massive mandate to keep Americans
safe and healthy, back to the websites, you're
a top patriot and he needs you to get this
t shirt to oppose her and the radical left
socialist and the radical socialist left because
Nancy Pelosi is a socialist. And then underneath
your will, you and one friend order your limited
edition T-shirt today, really, Shilan, four
for multiple t shirts to be sold. And then
here, which is a little bit more pernicious
and not quite as hilarious, is this fundraising
tactic that has been normalized across the
Republican Party platforms for fundraising.
If you've given up on House Republicans and
our fight against the socialist left unchecked,
this box. But if you still stand with us,
leave this box checked and make your monthly
donation to Bould Patriots fighting back against
Pelosi and this socialist left and then small
print make this a monthly reoccurring donation.
That is trickery. It is not clear what is
taking place there. Manipulating if you've
given up on the House, Republicans, uncheck
this box. But if you're still with us, you
Patriots, then check it and give us money
on a reoccurring monthly basis. A lot of people
who give to the Republican Party, as you can
see, it's it's default for occupation, retired
there. A lot of people are on a fixed income.
Donald Trump was just reported, had to give
back like one hundred and thirty five million
dollars or something wild like that. I don't
have the figure in my head, but have had to
refund money from people they were bilking
who were unaware that there was going to be
a continuing charge. So if you're interested
out there, you can go get your Moroun shirt
and walk around proclaiming to everyone just
how moronic
you are.